Joe Biden's campaign is unfortunately
for him increasingly going over like a
lead balloon disastrous results in Iowa
coming in fourth after polling second in
Iowa he's down to fourth place in the
polls for the New Hampshire primary
which is tomorrow and then over the
weekend Joe Biden called a female voter
a dog-faced pony soldier last week we
talked about Joe Biden strange sort of
overly aggressive behavior with some
male voters poking them in the chest
telling them to go vote for somebody
else this time it's a female voter check
out this video she asks about the Iowa
results Biden asks if she's ever
participated in a caucus and she says
yes and he calls her dog-faced weren't
burdened down by the impeachment piles
so so how do you explain the performance
in Iowa and why should the voters
believe that you can win the national
election it's a good question number one
I was a Democratic caucus there mendel
caucus no you haven't
you're a lying dog face pony-soldiers
you said you are but now you gotta be
honest I'm gonna be honest with you I
guess this is apparently some kind of
joke making fun of the caucus process
which believe me the caucus process
deserves plenty of ridicule but this is
not a good look this is actually not
even the first time Joe Biden has used
this term he did it at a rally in 2018
for senator Heidi Heitkamp and he
referred to the line as being from a
John Wayne movie to check it out this
seems to be the origin of Biden using
this phrase to use lines for movies a
John Wayne movie line
movie John we movin with Indians he
turns to John Wayne and says just a
lying dog phrase Pony soldier
well let me tell you these guys are
amazing now a bunch of people looked up
that line they tried to find that line
in a John Wayne movie and they weren't
able to so as I've said before I would
vote for Joe Biden in a second over
Donald Trump if Biden is the nominee but
we can't just write this stuff off as
generational Bernie Sanders is 14 months
older than Joe Biden and he's not
constantly saying this type of stuff you
could say well culturally you know
Bernie's from a Jewish New York family
it's a different world they might as
well be from different planets
altogether culturally compared to what
Biden grew up around okay Elizabeth
Warren is only seven years younger than
Biden and she also isn't saying this
stuff and she's from Oklahoma and lived
in Texas for a while whatever calling
women dog-faced is just bad even if it's
part of whatever Joe Biden thinks a
dog-faced pony soldier refers to from a
John Wayne movie that nobody is able to
find I am up for believing that this was
a joke and simply one that nobody
understood and there was no ill
intention behind it I won't even argue
with you I'm still asking how do you
make it to the convention if you're
calling voters dog-faced when they ask
reasonable questions like what the hell
happened to your results in Iowa and
then you tell them to vote for somebody
else when they come up and say hey will
you get us off fossil fuels or whatever
the case may be we're seeing Joe Biden's
campaign implode on a daily basis ending
up fourth in Iowa after polling second
going from polling first in New
Hampshire to polling fourth as of right
now with voting tomorrow and the way
things have gone I wouldn't be shocked
to see him end up fifth with clos Bashar
in fourth place in New Hampshire it's
early we don't know unclear in Nevada
and South Carolina what's going on
because we have infrequent polling there
he was doing well there but who knows
what's going on now falling from first
to second behind Bernie in California
barely holding a lead in Texas where he
had been leading for a long time I just
don't see how he can hold it together
through the DNC never mind through a
general
action campaign against Donald Trump if
he's the nominee I will vote for him
against Trump and I will have no doubt
that he is the better option Joe Biden /
Donald Trump increasingly it's feeling
unlikely given his performance but it's
important not to underestimate the power
of some Super Tuesday wins just three
weeks from now and of course the DNC is
going to have to decide do they do they
keep pushing Biden have they switched to
Budaj edge will they go to Bloomberg if
Bloomberg does well on Super Tuesday
where he is focusing essentially all of
his resources let me know what you make
about all of this I do want to hear from
you we will take a quick break and so
much more coming up today including an
analysis of the value-added tax we're
going to dig into the value-added tax
right after this short break one of our
sponsors today is a game called
lawgivers a turn based political
simulation game for PC iOS and Android
if you've ever wanted to start a
political party or run for office or
shape the destiny of our country here's
your chance I've been having a ton of
fun with the game you do get to
experience legislative democracy up
close and the dynamics of the game are
really impressive you make election
promises to your constituents it's up to
you whether you keep those promises when
you're in office all of the laws you
pass affect your country's happiness and
safety healthcare environment you can
abolish laws that are already in place
you can ratify the Constitution you
decide if you want the government to be
a healthy democracy or authoritarian
tyranny you can be corrupt and take
bribes political assassinations are part
of the game it's nuts actually it's a
really good time it doesn't get old
because you'll never play it the same
way twice this is not some cheesy
free-to-play game it's very clear that a
lot of time went into the development it
has very positive reviews on Steam and
in the App Store's four and a half stars
or higher on all platforms go to david
pakman.com slash game which is where you
can watch the trailer download the game
for Steam iOS and Android
that's david pakman.com slash game